música
[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy hablaremos del esequibo la
discordia histórica entre guyana y
venezuela como producto y resultado del
colonialismo en suramérica durante 180
años guyana y venezuela han sostenido un
pleito territorial que sigue sin
resolverse el esequibo es una región
limítrofe de ciento cincuenta y nueve
mil kilómetros cuadrados poco menos que
la extensión del estado de la florida en
eeuu que actualmente comprende el 75 por
ciento de guyana pero que venezuela
reclama como suyo desde el siglo 19 así
como chile y bolivia dirimieron la
salida al mar de este último ante la
corte internacional de justicia de la
haya con resultado a favor de los
chilenos en 2018 o tal comunicar agua
reclamo ante el mismo órgano de justicia
una porción de mar territorial de
colombia y lo consiguió en 2012 guyana
busca dejar por claro que el esequibo es
suyo tras el comienzo del juicio en la
haya el 26 de febrero de 2021 mientras
este se realiza y a sabiendas que una
negociación puede tardar más tiempo el
estimado por la corte interna
de justicia nos preguntamos cómo es el
origen de esta disputa y qué está en
juego la respuesta nos remonta al pasado
colonialista de guyana un territorio
suramericano bañado por el mar caribe y
habitado antiguamente por los indígenas
arahuacos y los caribes para el siglo 15
el acecho europeo era latente según
charles davidson actual obispo anglicano
en guyana la historia de su país es
interesante los franceses atravesaron el
territorio y por tal razón el cementerio
en georgetown se llama le haga dependido
o el arrepentimiento también estuvieron
los neerlandeses motivo por el cual una
ciudad se llama new amsterdam o nueva
ámsterdam y quienes más lo habitaron
fueron los británicos cuyo legado se
evidencia en que guyana es el único país
de suramérica cuya lengua oficial es el
inglés pero y los españoles en realidad
ellos fueron los primeros europeos que
incursionaron exploraron el territorio
con alonso de ojeda y pedro alonso niño
quienes navegaron el curso de los ríos
esequibo y orinoco sin embargo los
españoles descuidaron esta región y no
pudo
defender la provincia de guayana tras la
invasión holandesa de 1615 200 años
después de la invasión de los holandeses
y tras múltiples revueltas de esclavos
de la caña de azúcar en guyana los
británicos consiguieron que los países
bajos se dieran dichos territorios
mediante un tratado en 1814 para
conformar la guayana británica pero no
hubo claridad de por donde se marcaría
el trazado limítrofe con la capitanía
general de venezuela que por entonces le
pertenecía a la gran colombia esa
nebulosa fronteriza quiso ser aclarada
por los británicos en 1840 cuando le
pidieron a su explorador driver sound
board marcar una línea divisoria entre
venezuela y la guayana británica
mientras los venezolanos pensaban que
como territorio soberano su límite
oriental era el margen del río esequibo
los británicos anexionaron con el
trazado de schönberg cerca de 80 mil
kilómetros cuadrados hacia el occidente
indignados en 1841 hace 180 años los
venezolanos protestaron interna
y a sabiendas que no podían solos contra
los británicos acudieron a sus pares
americanos los estadounidenses aquí cabe
destacar dos puntos clave en la disputa
del esequibo y es que según el profesor
de economía de la universidad de wagner
michael moore el descubrimiento del oro
y la abolición de la esclavitud
cambiaron el curso económico de este
territorio codiciado por venezolanos y
británicos el esequibo encontró por la
influencia de los estadounidenses un
escenario judicial internacional para
ser dirimido llamado el laudo arbitral
de parís de 1899
los venezolanos tenían como argumento el
principio en derecho denominado uti
possidetis libre o como poseía seguirás
poseyendo aludiendo a su herencia
territorial recibida de los españoles
pero el resultado del tribunal parisino
favoreció a los ingleses y les adjudicó
el territorio del esequibo tal como lo
había trazado
robert sanberk la derrota venezolana
encontró en 1949 50 años después del
laudo arbitral de parís una supuesta
injerencia
los británicos en el voto decisivo del
jurista ruso fredrik martens de manera
que no sólo declararon nulo el fallo
sino que lo denunciaron ante la
organización de las naciones unidas en
1962 con un imperio británico en
decadencia y tres meses antes de que su
colonia guyana se declarara
independiente en 1966 londres firmó un
acuerdo internacional con caracas
conocido como el acuerdo de ginebra en
este quedó estipulado que el reino
unido- reconocida el reclamo territorial
venezolano y de no llegar a un pacto
entre las partes se concedía la potestad
al secretario general de las naciones
unidas para escoger la mejor forma de
resolverlo así pues y durante décadas
guyana se ha aferrado al laudo arbitral
de parís de 1899 y venezuela- al acuerdo
de ginebra de 1966 lo cierto es que el
esequibo se ha mantenido en controversia
con altos y bajos pero la disputa se
tensó en 2015 cuando la compañía
petrolera estadounidense exxonmobil
asegurara que bajo las aguas
continentales guyanesas
unas reservas petroleras estimadas entre
5500 a 8.000 millones de barriles dicho
recelo petrolífero a su sola venezuela
de nicolás maduró a manifestar la
reconquista y la defensa en todos los
planos del esequibo entretanto el juicio
en la corte internacional de justicia
comienza con un reparo y es que
venezuela ha expresado oficialmente que
no reconoce su jurisdicción y que tan
solo asiste en calidad de cortesía y no
como parte la historia de ir a quién se
queda con este territorio así concluimos
hoy andrés suárez jaramillo gracias por
compartir estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]